[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سنه 1991 استونيا اخذت استقلالها من
الاتحاد
السوفيتي استونيا تو دوله في الاتحاد
الاوروبي استونيا على سكانها اقل من مليون
ونص نسمه اسون تو تعتبر الدول الرائده في
مجال التقنيه الرقميه والخدمات
الالكترونيه قصه استونيا قصه لطيفه جدا
نعرضها انا في باجازه
يعني استونيا اخذ استقلالها في ال 91 سنه
98 جميع المدارس في استونيا تم ربطهم
بالانترنت سنه
2000 صار الحصول على الانترنت في استونيا
حق يضمن الدستور الاستوني شوف الدستور
الليبي نحن يطلع فيه
في
2003 تم انشاء شركه سكايب في استونيا
ماعرفش المعلومه هذه شركه سكايب شركه
استون تم بعدين شراها من مايكروسوفت وشركه
اخرى في 2007 اول انتخابات تمن عن طريق
الانترنت تمن في
استونيا الجراف الورا يوضح في مقارنه
لطيفه داروها الاي امف بين كوريا الجنوبيه
وغانا
من ناحيه الدخل بين الدولتين الدراسه هذه
مدوره ما بين سنه 1960 وسنه 2000 زي ما
شايفين في سنه 60 كانت
تقريبا نسبه الدخلع غانا وكوريا الجنوبيه
قريبات بعض حتى عد السكان كان قريبات
والدولتين هذنا كان يعتمد على مصادر
الثروات الطبيعيه اللي
عندهم في الاخر 50 70 سنه اللي فاتا صار
نمو في الكثافه السكانيه عند كوريا
الجنوبيه وهذا طبعا رفع من نسبه الاقتصاد
متاعهم الفرق اللي تحق فيه في سنه 2000
هنا هذا الفرق الطبيعي ما بين الدخل كوريا
وغانا بناء على نسبه الثروات الطبيعيه
اللي عندهم والكثافه السكانيه الموجوده
لكن حقيقه وين كوريا
قاعده كوريا دخل متاعها اعلى واجد والسبب
في ذلك ان الكوري
تمكنوا من زياده قيمه مضافه للاقتصاد
متاعها عن طريق الاستثمار في اقتصاد
المعرفه ولكن نمشي بالديت لتاريخ اليوم
حنق ان فارق زيد
واجد المشكله اللي فيها غانا هي مشكله
تواجه دول واجده السبب الحجه هذه ان دول
واجده معتمده على تصدير المواد الخام اللي
عندهم والمصادر الطبيعيه بس اللي عند ودول
نفطيه من اكثر الدول يعني ماشيه في
هذا خلونا ناخذ
مثال ليبيا واحده من الدول اللي معتمده
على صادرات المواد الخام اللي عندها بس
ونحنا عندنا مصدر واحد حوالي 90% من الدخل
متاع ليبيا يجي من نفط يعني تنويع
الاقتصاد عندنا شبه لا
يوجد في خلاف خصوصا في السنوات الاخيره
اللي فاتا ليبيا دوله غنيه ليبيا دوله
فقيره وين وضعنا نحن في العالم القصه هذه
هي غنيه وفقيره موضوع نسبي في العاده لكن
انت اللي يهمك انت وين موقعك من الاعراب
في العالم انت وين قاعد نحكي اقتصاديا انت
وين سنه 2010 كانت من في السنوات الاخيره
سعر النفط كان عالي ودخل ليبيا كان يعني
يعتبر عالي نسبيا في تاريخ ليبيا
الحديثه سنه 2010 داخل ليبيا كان اقل من
عشر في من الاقتصاد العالمي يعني نسبه
تاثيرها في الاقتصاد
العالمي لا
تك النفط الليبي اللي نحن نقول عننا نفط
ناثر ه كلنا شفنا في السنوات
الاخيره نظر ظروف توقف شبه تام لتصدير
النفط ليبي وهذا ما اثرش في اي حاجه في
اقتصاد العالم بان اسعار النفط طحن
و اكيد ما طحن عشان النفط الليبي ولا عشان
الاقتصاد الليبي يعني في ظروف ظروف
اخرى فنحنا و اقتصادنا
ضعيف المشكله وين المشكله في الدول اللي
تصدر في مصادرها الطبيعيه ويقد عندها دخل
جاي من فقط منص الطبيعيه الدوله
تستسهل
الاستثمارات تق عباره عن الدوله توزع
الدخل اللي عندها على الناس وهذا ياثر
طبعا شنو قله الانتاجيه
هذا مثال موجود في عديد من الدول ليبيا
حده منهن اللي معتمده على مصدر واحد او
شبه معتمده علىيه مصدر واحد من الدخل اللي
هي الزياده الكبيره جدا في القطاع العام
ونسبه التوظيف في القطاع
العام القوه العامله في ليبيا تمثل
حوالي 90% من القطاع
العام في ارقام واج احصائيات وجدات لكن
تقريبيا في مليون ونص موظف يخدموا في
الدوله
الليبيه رقم واجد مش واجد المشكله وين في
ليبيا وخصوصا بالنسبه للقطاع
العام ان القطاع العام الليبي ما يحتاج
اكثر من 500000 موظف بل ان في
دراسات للوضع الليبي يقول ان القطاع العام
الليبي المفروض ما يزيد على 200000 بس
خلينا نمشي على 500000 500000 عننا معناها
مليون زياده عننا مليون موظف ما ينتج عننا
مليون موظف ياخذ في راتب ما يدير فيه
وظيفه هذ ممكن يكون عندهم بعض الاسباب
وتبريرات سياسيه او حتى اجتماعيه لكن من
ناحيه اقتصاديه حظ ما تقدرش تستمر
صعبه تو نحن وين
بنمش لازم نب
نقوا مليون فرصه عمل لان من غير مليون
فرصه عمل
هنا مش بس الاقتصاد يتدهور حتى القطاع
العام بروحه اللي هو خدماتها مدهوره
يتدهور زياده لان ماش حيقدر ياخذ ياخذ
فرص بدايه الحل في الموضوع هذا ان نحن
لازم ننظر
للمليون
موظف مليون شخص اللي في القطاع العام ه
الزياده ان ه فرصه ان المليون شخص هذ ممكن
حضيف من القيمه الانتاجيه للاقتصاد الليبي
وهذا يقعد التركيز بعنا طبعا هم ه في
الغالب حوا القطاع الخاص او الشراكات ما
بين القطاع العام والقطاع الخاص ما
يعرف
يعني لكن لازم ننتقل بها فت نحاول بنشرح
شنو وين نحن ممكن نتجه وين التوجهات وكيف
نحن الخطوات اللي ممكن ناخذهم في هذا
الاتجاه عشان انت توفر مليون فرصه عمل نحن
اللي
نحتاجه حوالي 1000 ما يعرف رائد اعمال او
الانتور نبوا 1000 ال000 هذوما خلال عش
سنوات الجايات مطلوب منهم
يديروا 100 الا مشروع يعني كل واحد بدير
لنا ع مشاريع او شركات في ع سنين
الجايات لكن احنا ما نبوش اي نوع مشاريع
نبوا مشاريع اللي يزيدا من القيمه المضافه
للاقتصاد الليبي عشان هيك انت في المشاريع
هذنا تحتاج توظف بعض الاشخاص اللي عندهم
مهارات معينه
او مهارات معرفيه عاليه و متخصصه في حاجه
حاجه معينه عشان انت تزيد من القيمه مضافه
الاقتصاد فكل مشرو يحتاج حوالي ع من
الاشخاص هذوما بال 10 الا يطلع عننا
[موسيقى]
100000 وظيفه بالع سنين جايات هذو خاصين
اللي عندهم المهارات الخاصه سبيشال سكيلز
هذين اللي ممكن
يساعدنا دراسات واجهه اصيه تقول ان كل
وظيفه مباشره ذو قيمه معرفيه عاليه حتجيب
وراها ع وظائف غير مباشره يعني ال 100000
هذين حيجيب لنا باقي المليون لكن ننا هي
الشغل خلاص وين نتوجه وين تركيز الشغل
بعنا في
دراسه ع الرين الكتاب هذا واش لماذا تسقط
الدول والامم كتاب قيم جدا يعني ملخص
الكتاب هو دار دراسات من بدايه التاريخ
للحضارات
والدول ليش هذ نجح ليش هذنا وخصوصا من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه ولخص في الملخص في
الاخير ان التكنولوجيا والتقنيه هي اهم
العوامل لنجاح وازار
الدول كلو رقم واحد او توجه رقم واحد نحنا
لازم نستثمر في مجالات التقنيه اللي عندهم
دور ليش ن الحاجات هذنا لان هذنا اللي
حيطنا قيمه مضافه
للاقتصاد رقم ا لما انت جيت بتخصص في
موضوع معين شنو تخصص او شنو المجال اللي
انت المفروض تختاره نحن شفنا اقتصاد ليبيا
صغير جدا معناها انت
عندك لما انت تبي تختار موضوع خذ
حاجه مشكله عالميه مشكله كبيره
في مواضيع الطاقه في الصحه في البيئه
العالم في مشاكل واجده لكن لازم تاخذ ش
مشكله عالميه مش مشكله بس خاصه عندك انت
هنا وفي نفس الوقت شوف التكنولوجي ترند او
مسارات التقنيه وين مشيت نقطه التلاقي هذه
ما بين التحديات
العالميه وين التكنولوجيا وين ماشيه هي
النقطه اللي انت تبدا تركز فيها
ليش واحد ننا اصدنا صغير فانت تبي سوق
اكبر اثنين نحن لازم يقد عننا دور في
المساهمه في حل مشاكل العالم لازم نلعب
دور في حل مشاكل الصحه في البيئه وما الى
ذلك ف هذه النقطه
الاولى لما انت تبدا اي مشروع في الغالب
انت حتكون في واحد من اربع مربعات هذنا
المربع المثالي اللي انت تبي توصل لله
مربع رقم عه المربع اربعه
تتقى جوجل وفيسبوك والجماعه كلهم قاعدين
اربعه ل انت في الغالب في البدايه حتبدا
بمربع رقم واحد ليش لان بال الغالب ما
عندش استمارات واجد عشان تبدا المشروع
اثنين حتى خبرتك الفنيه في الموضوع ممكن
ما تكونش واجد فمعناها انت ش تبي
تدير تبي تحاول باسرع وقت انك تنتقل من
مربع رقم واح مربع رقم
اثنين المؤسسين شركه جوجل لما بدوا بدوا
في مربع رقم اثنين ما كانش عندهم فلوس
ليستثمر هم بس كانت عندهم فكره وكانت
عندهم مهارات فنيه كويسه لما انت مربع رقم
اثنين تبذل مجهود و ممكن شويه حظ ممكن
تنتقل المربع رقم اربعه لما توصل المربع
رقم اربعه الشركه بتاعك او المشروع بعك
يوظف الاف والالاف الفرص هذين ح يوفر
عشرات الالاف الفرص غير
فرص عمل غير
مباشره نحن عايشين في وقت مثالي جدا في
التقدم التكنولوجي والتكنولوجيا قاعده
تصارع بطريقه سريعه جدا فانا اخترت
اربع تقنيات انا شايف ان حيكون لهم دور
مثالي في الفتره الجايه انترنت الاشياء
دكتور عاد حكي عليها في الصبح او ما يعرف
الانترنت بيانات ضخمه بيج ديتا
التكنولوجيا الحيويه بايوتيك والنانو
تكنولوجي او تكنولوجيا ال باختصار نحكي
على كل وحده
بسرعه انترنت
الاشياء العالم قاعد كلها متصل بعضها
دراسه هذه
داتها شركه اركسون في 2014 توري ان في
حوالي مليار جهاز كمبيوتر متصلات بعضهم
فوق من 6 مليار جهاز نقال بد يتصل مع
بعضهم التوقعات ان في 20 20 في فوق من 50
مليار حاجه او
شي
تلفزيونك سيارتك مكيف حصير في تواصل
بيناته كميه الاجه اصل مع بعضهم ميزه
ومشكله في نفس الوقت والتحديات اللي ه
حيطلع عنه ه ه فيه فرص
استثمار
انترنت الغالب ال ماشي على الاقل تو في
الفتره القصيره في المصانع والاشياء
الصناعيه في حيكون فيها تقدم
كبير البج ديتا الب
ديتا هو تقنيه تخصصه ان كيف انت تتعامل مع
كميات كبيره من البيانات ومش بس بيانات
ديتا كحجم لكن حتى انواع التا انت لازم
تعامل مع فيديو وصوت وديتا وانك ديتا
وحاجات واجده وكله جياتك في ري تايم
وسريعات بكل فانت كيف تتعامل معهن وتحلله
وتطلع منه معلومات الصوره ورايه هذه
توري شركه الفيسبوك تجمع في السنه كلكم
استعمل
الفيسبوك حوالي 300 ال تيرابايت كميه ديتا
كبيره جدا فيس في السنه بالمقارنه شركه رز
رويس وحده من الشركات الكبيره اللي صنعه
في محركات الطيارات المحركات الجديده
الطيارات اللي صنع فيه رزرو
فيضغط
الحراره في شبه ري تيم
دي شركه را قبا في كل طيارات العالم طول
الوقت اللي يتحرك شركه روز رويز في السنه
تجمع اقل من اربعه مليار تيرا بايت انت لو
تشوف المقارنه اللي بالازرق هذا هذه ديتا
الجمع فيها روز رويس في السنه مقارنه
بالابيض شويه الفيسبوك عشان يعطيك حجم
الفرق في
الاثنين البايو تيك هو
علم مش جديد واجد هو لكن في تقدمات كبيره
صايره الفتره الاخيره وهو ان كيف تعدل
تستخدم التقنيه
الحيويه انك تطور منتجات وخدمات مفيده
هذنا
عندهم فرص كبيره خصوصا في في تحسين
المحاصيل الزراعيه مممكن المتحدث
السابق كلامم اللي قال على ان نستفيد منها
في بارقه فرصه لبعض الانتنا اللي هنا ممكن
نستخدمه التقنيه اللي بعدها النانو
تكنولوجي النانو تكنولوجي هو علم ان كيف
انت تعدل و وتصمم
مواد تعامل معهم على مستوى
النانومتر فكره النانومتر كيف سمك الجريده
صفحه الجريده صفحه جريده وحده السمك
متاعها حوالي 100 الف
ذره صفحه الجري حده 100 ال ذره التقنيه
بكن تشتغل ذره ذره تغير ذره ذره وهذا
يعطيك امكانيه انك تتحكم في العناصر
بطريقه
اكبر
السبب في اختيار الاربع المجالات هذنا انك
انت ماكش محتاج معامل كبيره وحاجات عشان
تبدا الحاجات ين انت في تولز وادوات واجده
تقدر تنزله وصفت ويرات من الانترنت محتاج
فكره محتاج تطور نفسك انك تطلع برودكت او
خدمه
انك تدير منها منتج وعمل
تجاري نرجع
لكتاب واشن التركيز
لازم يقعد ان نحن نطور اقتصادنا
في مجال يرفع من القيمه المضافه للاقتصاد
الليبي والافضل مجال حسب الدراسه هذه من
بدايه التاريخ هو الاستمارات في مواضيع
التكنولوجيا
والتقنيه عشان هك نحن لازم نشتغل مع بعضنا
عشان نحن نخلق المليون فرصه عمل هذنا نبوا
نتعاونوا مع بعضنا عشان ننشئ 10 الا مشروع
اطلقنا هاشتاج 10000 مشروع تبعوا
المواضيع لان ال 10000 مشروع هذين اللي
حقوه هنا اللي حيجيب لنا المليون فرصه عمل
شكرا